Actor Brandon Routh, who donned the red cape
and proudly wore the "S" on his chest in 2006's
Superman Returns, is flying back onto the
small screen for the upcoming Arrowverse crossover
event "Crisis on Infinite Earths."
Though Routh already has an Arrowverse role,
portraying Ray Palmer, the Atom, as a regular
on DC's Legends of Tomorrow, he'll reprise
his role as Superman along with current Arrowverse
Clark Kent-slash-Superman Tyler Hoechlin,
who plays Big Blue on Supergirl.
But just how and why will he be wearing the
red, blue and yellow again?
Routh's tenure as the silver-screen Superman
was short-lived; he only appeared as the Man
of Tomorrow in Bryan Singer's Superman Returns.
Routh was just 24 when he auditioned, and
Singer sung his praises, likening him to iconic
Superman actor Christopher Reeve and describing
him as the embodiment of the world's, quote,
"collective memory of Superman" thanks to
his physical appearance and his Midwestern
upbringing much like Clark Kent's own.
Critics largely agreed with Singer's assessment
of Routh, praising his performance.
Yet Superman Returns underperformed at the
box office.
Warner Bros. and Legendary Pictures decided
that the sequel they had planned wouldn't
happen after all.
When Warner Bros. announced in August 2008
that the franchise would be rebooted, Routh
hoped to hang on to the role.
Even after his Superman contract expired in
2009, Routh still hoped to portray the superhero
again.
Ultimately, though, Routh wasn't asked to
return: Warner Bros. instead handed Henry
Cavill the cape for Man of Steel, which he
followed with appearances in Batman v. Superman
and Justice League.
When Arrowverse producers rang him up, the
emotion hit him hard:
"I hoped maybe there'd be an opportunity sometime,
but didn't really think that actually would
happen, so I kinda felt like a little kid,
very shocked and excited."
Sure, it was something he had hoped might
happen, but was it too late?
Would anyone even want to see him as the Last
Son of Krypton again?
And worse yet, would he somehow experience
the same disappointment he had with Superman
Returns?
In an interview at San Diego Comic-Con 2019,
he told Entertainment Weekly he felt a "mix
of feelings" when he was first approached
about appearing again as Superman.
But obviously, Routh accepted the offer.
He said "Crisis on Infinite Earths" is his
second chance at giving the superhero a proper
send-off:
"It's an opportunity for me to kind of say
hello and goodbye to the character in a way
that I didn't get to do the first time."
"Crisis on Infinite Earths" will span five
episodes of the various Arrowverse shows ⁠— Supergirl,
Arrow, The Flash, Legends of Tomorrow, and
the new Batwoman ⁠— starting in December
2019 and ending in January 2020.
"We shoulda done a crossover."
"Yeah."
According to Deadline, Routh and fellow Superman
Hoechlin will play versions of Superman, quote,
"in different time frames," suggesting that
they may not meet up on screen.
But considering how the Crisis on Infinite
Earths story played out in the comics, it's
likely that the pair are playing Supermen
from different Earths who will work together
to save the universe.
If that's the case, "Crisis on Infinite Earths"
will not only allow Routh the chance to say
goodbye to Superman, but it will also give
him the opportunity to team up with another
Superman who will presumably keep the cape
flying on television for years to come.
And Routh is clearly stoked about the whole
situation, writing to Hoechlin on Twitter,
"So excited to share the screen with you as
Supes @tylerhoechlin!
So fun!
I'm so ready!"
But how will Routh's other Arrowverse character,
Ray Palmer, fit in?
Chatting with IGN host Max Scoville at Comic-Con,
Routh said it'll be interesting if he gets
to play both the Atom and Superman for "Crisis
on Infinite Earths," because they're such
similar characters.
"Ray is kind of modeled a little bit after
Clark.
There are definitely Clark...Clark energy
in Ray.
Um, so I'd say, you know, there's a fair bit
of crossover."
See Routh finally return as Superman when
the "Crisis on Infinite Earths" event beings
this December on the CW.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.